my name is Sarah baleen I'm the events
director here at Cramer books and on
behalf of the entire staff I'm so
pleased to welcome you and I'm really
pleased to welcome Bruce tonight for his
book JFK's forgotten crisis in the book
Bruce shares the gripping story of the
conflict that really has escaped
history's attention but it really still
resonates today it's that of the
sino-indian war he draws on newly
declassified documents and details the
decisions made by JFK to send the tide
of an all-out war and explained how this
forgotten crisis is still influencing
the world more than half a century later
we're so glad that he's here with us to
share his new book please join me in
welcoming Bruce Riedel to Kramer books
[Applause]
that's good I think thank you very much
Sarah for that introduction and thank
all of you for coming out tonight
I want to begin by taking you back a
half a century on the morning of October
16th 1962 McGeorge Bundy John F Kennedy
is national security adviser arrived at
his office in the West Wing of the White
House on his desk as there was every
morning there was a file prepared by the
White House Situation Room of the most
important top-secret documents that he
had to see before he saw the president
that day two documents were notably
important on the 16th of October one was
a memo from the State Department from
the Bureau of intelligence and research
and in that document the State
Department warned that the situation
between China and India on their border
in the Himalaya Mountains was
deteriorating rapidly and that there was
a very good chance that a war was going
to break out between China and India the
document also warned the president that
if that happened India would probably be
the loser and that the United States
might be called upon by India's Prime
Minister Nehru to provide assistance and
support to stem the Chinese invasion it
also warned him that if he did provide
support to India
that would alienate our ally in South
Asia Pakistan and could lead to a crisis
in us-pakistani relations the other
document that morning was a report from
the Central Intelligence Agency and in
it it summarized the result of a recent
YouTube overflight of the island of Cuba
the CIA had discovered just today before
that the Soviet Union was in the process
of putting intermediate-range ballistic
missiles in Cuba which had the capacity
to hit almost every American city east
of the Mississippi River it was a global
game changer by the Soviets in
retrospect one of these crises is well
known we've all seen movies about the
Cuban Missile Crisis we've seen books
about the Cuban Missile Crisis there's a
whole industry of studies about the
Cuban Missile Crisis and there should be
the Cuban Missile Crisis was the closest
we came to Armageddon in the Cold War
John F Kennedy was dealing with an issue
which if he dealt with it wrong would
have meant we wouldn't be here today the
apocalypse would have occurred in fact
we now know 50 years later that it was
even more dangerous than people thought
it was then the CIA back in 1962
estimated there were six to eight
thousand Soviet soldiers on the island
in fact there were 50,000 Soviet
soldiers on the island the CIA thought
that the Soviets had only brought
intermediate-range ballistic missiles in
fact the Russians had also brought with
them tactical nuclear weapons and they'd
surrounded the Guantanamo Naval Base
with what were called frog missiles and
the commander of the Soviet forces on
the island had the authority already
delivered from Moscow that when the
first American bomb dropped on Cuba he
could fire a salvo of tactical nuclear
weapons into the Guantanamo Naval Base
where there were 5,000 Marines
but just as that process was so
important
it shouldn't completely overlook the
other crisis the sino-indian war China
and India are the world's two biggest
countries by virtue of population and
back in the 1960s they were the cutting
edge of a competition between democracy
and communism in many ways they were
where the whole Cold War was really
going to be fought out and Kennedy had
actually campaigned in 1959 in 1960 one
of the planks that he campaigned on was
the United States wanted India to win
this competition the State Department
memo was remarkably prescient they got
it absolutely right a few days later the
war degan and the Chinese immediately
began over running the front line Indian
positions within a week or two India was
in a very serious very serious position
and looked like it was going to be
defeated Nehru as the State Department
predicted did very very reluctantly
asked the United States and the United
Kingdom for assistance and by the end of
October 1962 the United States and the
Royal Air Force were flying a massive
airlift of weapons and equipment in into
India six 707s were landing every day at
New Delhi International Airport and from
there
American c-130s were taking equipment to
the front lines in the Himalayas and in
Kashmir then the Chinese stopped they
paused for a week and then they started
again
with an even larger offensive at the end
of November this offensive threatened to
overrun all of eastern India if you
think of India there's that little neck
part that sticks out beyond Bangladesh
Bangladesh of course in 1962 was East
Pakistan all of that part looked like it
was going to fall into Chinese hands and
it was unclear whether the Chinese would
stop there there were some in India who
thought the Chinese would march all the
way to Calcutta and take India's second
largest city
on November 19th 1962 the crisis came to
its head
Nehru sent to Kennedy two letters the
first letter arrived just before a
National Security Council meeting the
second letter arrived during the meeting
but the American ambassador in New Delhi
John Kenneth Galbraith and I'll come
back to him in a minute
had already previewed the second letter
the second letter was a cry for
immediate assistance in it Nehru said we
are on the verge of going under the
whole world is going to see a communist
giant marched into a democracy and
destroy it I'm not sure India will
survive this catastrophe and then he
came to the punchline he said he
immediately needed 12 squadrons of
American combat fighter aircraft with
American pilots and two more squadrons
of American bombers to be snatched
immediately to India to join in the war
in this letter Nehru was asking the
President of the United States for 350
combat aircraft to be deployed
immediately into India to defend Indian
airspace while India began bombing raids
into Tibet
it was obviously going to be a slippery
slope once we went into India we were
going to be at war with Communist China
the president that night decided that he
needed time he couldn't make this
decision overnight and he did two things
first he dispatched a US Navy carrier
battle group to the Bay of Bengal in
order to demonstrate American support
for India secondly he sent Averell
Harriman on an urgent mission left
actually left that night from Andrews
Air Force Base to fly direct to India to
assess India's needs at the time Averell
Harriman is not well remembered today
but he's an icon of American diplomacy
Averell Harriman is demanded Franklin
Delano Roosevelt sent to London during
the Blitz to assess whether the
British we're going to survive the Nazi
onslaught he's the man FDR sent to
Moscow in 1941 to see whether the Soviet
Union was going to be able to survive
the Nazi invasion this was the biggest
big gun that you could possibly find
anywhere he did something else as well
and he'd been doing it several in the
beginning of the crisis he sent another
message to Pakistan saying don't even
think about it because from the
beginning of the crisis the Pakistani
military dictator Ayub Khan had been
sending signals that a he was very
unhappy America was supporting India and
B he therefore wanted to be compensated
as we like to say for Pakistan's
neutrality and compensation meant give
me Kashmir Kennedy refused to give in to
this blackmail and he sent repeated
messages to the Pakistanis that if you
enter this war we will regard you as
part of the enemy not as part of the
alliance that we have with you the 20th
of November was sheer panic in New Delhi
John Kenneth Galbraith writes in his
memoirs that it looked like India was
going to disintegrate all Indian
aircrafts private and public were
commissioned commissioned by the Indian
Air Force martial law was declared in
much of northeast India and India
belatedly began moving troops from the
Pakistan front even though it feared a
second front could open up and then that
night for no explanation
China unilaterally stopped the Chinese
ceased their offensive and announced
that within a month they would draw back
to the lines where they had started we
don't know why China did that Chinese
records are not available today you can
get a lot of records about what the
American government thought about what
the Indian government thought but
Chinese archives remain sealed Nehru
credited John F Kennedy with convincing
the Chinese to stop he told John Kenneth
Galbreath that it was America's resolve
and Kennedy's determination not to let
the Chinese win manifested in the
airlift and manifested in the deployment
of the aircraft carrier battle group
that persuaded Beijing to stop and not
let this crisis continue to go any
further this of course leaves us with
the great what if what if the Chinese
hadn't stopped that night would the
United States have found itself at war
with Communist China
remember in 1962 only been nine years
before when we had been at war with
Communist China in Korea fought a war in
Korea with the Communist Chinese for the
better part of three years and here
Nehru was essentially asking us to go to
war with China again we'll never know
it's a what-if but in my judgment
Kennedy almost certainly would have said
yes and I make that judgment for several
reasons first because he really did
believe that Indian democracy was
crucial to the United States in the
global balance of power second because
his ambassador John Kenneth Galbraith
who was a personal friend and one of the
people closest to the president would
almost certainly have recommended it and
third because just a year later in the
fall of 1963 the United States Air Force
the Royal Air Force and small squadrons
from the Royal Australian Air Force and
the Royal Canadian Air Force deployed
into India for a military training
exercise which was exactly what Nehru
had asked for a year before so we
actually practiced going into this war
the conflict between China and India
ended in a ceasefire unilaterally on the
21st of November 1962 but the conflicts
not over China and India have never
settled their border dispute this border
dispute remains the longest unsettled
border dispute in the world today
neither party agrees to wear that border
should be there have been hundreds of
meetings between the Chinese and Indians
and they haven't succeeded one iota
moving forward they are big trading
partners with each other today the
likelihood of another China India war is
probably pretty low I wouldn't say the
same thing about the likelihood of
another india-pakistan war that I think
is probably a very serious reality so
that dispute continues to this day and
in addition that dispute has led to two
other things and access between China
and Pakistan China and Pakistan had
barely any interaction with each other
before 1962 but if you look back in 50
years perspective it's 1962 or the
alliance between China and Pakistan
begins and today that Alliance is very
strong they call it the all-weather
alliance it's kind of a snub that the
United States we're not all whether they
are all whether they say it's taller
than the Himalayas and deeper than the
Indian Ocean and just this year China
and Pakistan signed agreements which
will lead to 46 billion dollars in
Chinese investment in Pakistani
infrastructure and of course it heads
another dimension their secret nuclear
collusion Pakistan and China have been
secret nuclear partners since the 1960's
China gave Pakistan the designs for its
nuclear weapons force and today Pakistan
has the fastest growing nuclear weapons
program in the world faster than any
other country this is also led to a
triangular arms race probably the most
dangerous arms race in the world today
between China and Pakistan on the one
hand and India on the other just two
years ago India proudly announced that
had fired an intermediate-range
ballistic missile that allowed it for
the first time to target Beijing with
nuclear weapons so the crisis that was
averted in 1962 remains a problem even
to this day
john f kennedy's forgotten store crisis
is the story of that crisis mostly from
the American point of view it also has
several other backstories which I'd be
happy to talk about in Q&A like the role
played by the first lady who's very
important in this whole issue and the
role played by the CIA in trying to
sponsor her rebellion in Tibet but let
me just finish with one final word about
sources this book relies upon letters
that have only been Declassified in the
last couple of years between Kennedy and
Nehru for more than 50 years the Indian
government denied these letters even
existed because in some ways they're
very very embarrassing India at its
moment of greatest need
had to ask United States to bail it out
the letters are declassified and this is
the first book that takes advantage of
looking at those documents in depth with
that thank you very much for your
attention and I'd be delighted to take
questions if I can come up with answers
[Applause]
and if not only started I would love to
hear about the first lady you know right
John F Kennedy never went to India and
Pakistan during the thousand days that
he was in office he he had gone to India
in the early 1950s and mrs. Kennedy
actually recounts what happened she
didn't go with him but it's a great
anecdote she said that when the then
Senator John F Kennedy got to New Delhi
and they requested a meeting with the
Prime Minister
the u.s. embassy told him that the prime
minister's attention often failed pretty
quickly and that if the prime minister's
attention was failing he'd start to look
up at the ceiling and start playing with
his pencil within two minutes of the
meeting with John F Kennedy
according to Jackie's Nehru was staring
up at the ceiling and playing with his
pencils so it was not a very auspicious
part for their relationship it got
better but mrs. Kennedy's did travel to
South Asia during the thousand days of
the kennedy administration she went in
the spring of 1962 so just a few months
before the crisis it was the first time
a first lady had traveled by herself
outside the United States in the age of
television Eleanor Roosevelt had
traveled during the Second World War but
there was no television and Truman and
Eisenhower zwipes never traveled by
themselves overseas now when I say by
herself that's a little bit of a
misnomer her sister went whither a
Secret Service detachment of about 25
people they had they needed a Boeing 707
to get them there as well
her trip was a spectacular success
she was hailed as the queen of America
in India and Pakistan and she excited
the crowds not just in India and
Pakistan but because of television she
excited the people back in the United
States of America
in Pakistan I obtained also gave her her
gift he'd heard that she was a horse
woman that she loved horses that she
loved riding that she loved jumping with
them so he gave her a ten year old
gelding named xodar the DAR means chief
in dari and she laid immediate
instructions back to the White House
that sadar was to be given VIP treatment
flown home on its errand airplane and
there was going to be nothing about the
silly rules about checking the
veterinary background - this horse was
to be shipped immediately to her farm
well it is the DAR that bride's
riderless behind john f kennedy's
caisson during the funeral of
Pennsylvania Avenue and over to
Arlington Park it's kind of a unique
reminder of the role India and Pakistan
played in the in the kennedy
administration the other thing she did
of course was she was a hostess she
hosted both Ayub Khan and Nehru for
state visits to the United States the
state visit for field marshal Ayub Khan
was unique only once in American history
has Mount Vernon George Washington's
home been used for state visit
Jackie wanted to use Mount Vernon she
had just come back from a trip with her
husband to Versailles in France and the
Schonbrunn palace in Austria but we
don't have any palaces but she wanted to
do something equally grand so in June
1961 Mount Vernon was the site of a very
special summit between Ayub Khan and
John F Kennedy a few months later Nehru
came it was in November and Nehru they
had to now of course if you'd had
Mountain Vernon for the Pakistani what
do you do to outdo that
so they took Nehru to Jackie's home in
Newport
Rhode Island Hammersmith farms it's
called a cottage but if you've ever
driven around Newport you'll realize
their idea of a cottage is a lot
different than most of us but it turned
out to be a complete failure nehru at
this point was getting on in age he was
very tired he was very exhausted from
the flight he answered most of Kennedy's
requests and most of Kennedy's thoughts
with mono syllabic short answers there
was no engagement and then it got worse
after the stop in Newport they came down
to the White House to have official
dinner in the White House as well and
somebody on the White House staff failed
to properly open the flue in the
fireplace in the East Room and the
meeting began with smoke spreading
throughout the White House was not a
very auspicious starting to their
relationship but mrs. Kennedy in this
regard was was it was a crucial partner
with her husband in the American
engagement with both India and Pakistan
in the early 1960s
yeah I wonder if these documents are
wondering if these documents shed any
light on the CIA involvement in Tibet
and on the GA support for the khumba's
in their guerrilla fight against the
Chinese sure let me back up just a
little bit in the 1950s Pakistan was
America who is called America's most
allied ally we actually had more
treaties of alliance with Pakistan than
we did with any other country in the
world Pakistan was a member of the
central treaty organization was a member
of the Southeast Asia Treaty
Organization we were firmly in bed with
the Pakistanis the Eisenhower
administration liked Pakistan because it
was clearly with us in the Cold War
whereas India was a much more neutral
posture the CIA as a result developed a
very close relationship with its
Pakistani counterpart in the 1950s one
of these relationships was the famous
YouTube a youtube aircraft were based in
Peshawar in Pakistan that's where they
took off to fly over the Soviet Union
that's where the the famous mission who
was shot down began in 1959 there was a
second secret operation and that was to
support the Tibetan resistance 1950
China moved troops into Tibet the story
of whether Tibet is part of China or not
part of China you can go to the to a
library there are bookshelves full of
books arguing both sides of it I'm not
going to go into that today from the
Tibetan standpoint it was pretty
clear-cut their country was invaded by
the Chinese their way of life was
attacked by China in many ways and their
spiritual leader the Dalai Lama was
forced into exile or went into exile
what few people know is that when the
Dalai Lama went into exile it was a CIA
team of trained Tibetans that
helped him get out of Tibet and cross
over the border into India where he's
remains to this day the CIA was also
providing military support to Tibetan
rebels fighting against the Communist
army the People's Liberation Army and
that support was provided from an
airbase in Pakistan in what is today
Bangladesh what at the time was East
Pakistan if you think about the
geography where can you get at to that
easily from Bangladesh or East Pakistan
is placed very close by the CIA trained
some of the operatives in the United
States some of them were trained at the
CIA's training facility in Camp Perry in
Virginia but most of them were trained
in Colorado and the logic of that was
that Colorado is as close to Tibet in
terms of geography and climate as you
can find anywhere in the United States I
don't know whether that's really true or
not but that was the logic they were
trained at at a US Army facility that
had been used to keep captured German
soldiers in World War two they were
trained there they were then flown to
East Pakistan and then parachuted into
Tibet in many ways it was a crazy
operation there was no possible way the
Tibetans with all the American support
in the world we're going to actually
defeat the Chinese People's Liberation
Army John Kenneth Galbraith thought the
whole idea was was crazy even called it
unsanitary not sure that why exactly he
picked that but it's one of his
arguments the operation continued after
the Eisenhower administration into the
Kennedy administration the documents
that I alluded to about relationship
between arrow and Kennedy don't speak to
it very much
officially the Indians were out of the
loop I'm increasingly convinced that the
Indians must have been aware of at least
part of what was going on after all
they're immediately next door but
they were they were not involved in the
operation at this point but we do have
fortunately a - very very good accounts
of the operation written by CIA officers
who were involved in it and who got
their memoirs published cleared by the
CIA's review process which provide a
very very in-depth report on what was
going on just to go back take you back
to Mountain Vernon for one more minute
the business between Kennedy and Ayub
Khan that night was top secret I
obtained the month before the mountain
Fernand Sunnat had turned off use of the
Air Force Base in East Pakistan he
wanted to send Kennedy a message if you
want to flirt with the Indians if you
want to give India economic assistance
it's going to cost you something he
didn't want to do this in public he
didn't want to have a public falling-out
so the easiest way to send the message
was to cut off a covert program the
Americans would know the rest of the
world wouldn't necessarily know it
wouldn't become a big issue Kennedy at
that dinner that night in addition to a
lot of Senators and cabinet members also
invited the Director of Central
Intelligence Allen Dulles and when
everyone else was having their mint
juleps and orange juice before dinner
Kennedy took Ayub Khan for a walk in the
gardens around Mount Vernon and asked
him would you let us continue the
operation to fight Communist Chinese
would you resume use of the Tibet pace
and either because of the charm of the
night or the charm of the President or
maybe because he always intended to he
agreed to and resumed the assistance
resumed that operation now flash forward
to April Harriman what Averell Harriman
arrives in India he has three items on
his agenda one is a political agenda how
to work between India and Pakistan
second is a military general how much
more military assistance to get to the
Indians what kind of assistance
what kind of joint training operations
should we pursue and the covert agenda
because now that China and India had
gone to war the CIA and the White House
judge the Indians were ready to replace
the Pakistanis and they were right and
the Indians now began to support the
Tibetan resistance and CIA flights now
started coming out of India to drop
equipment to the Chinese the other thing
that began was u2 flights heretofore
YouTube flights had only come out of
Pakistan in 1963 in 1964
YouTube YouTube flights now had come out
secretly from air bases in India and it
was one of those air flights from a
Indian facility that discovered that the
Chinese were in the final stages of
preparing to test their first nuclear
weapon and gave the United States the
crucial intelligence that China was on
the verge of becoming a nuclear weapons
state
idea
the only other thing I'd like to share
just say a word about the ambassador
in New Delhi John Kenneth Galbraith
because he's a huge part of this book
John Kenneth Galbraith was a tall man
six foot six he was born in Ontario in
Canada he's a graduate of the Ontario
School of Agriculture he then moved to
the United States became an economist
wrote several books in the 1940s and
1950s about economics and became one of
the stars of Harvard University one of
if not the star of Harvard University in
the 1950s and he also became an advisor
to Kennedy he wrote he kept a diary
while he was ambassador to New Delhi and
he later published that diary for a
historian of course the diary is gold
because it's not a memoir a memoirs
written later and you put in how
brilliant you were whether or not you
were or not a diary you write at the
time and you may still say you were
brilliant but at least we know you
actually said that on the 19th of
November 1962 or otherwise the diary is
a fascinating piece of very unpolitical
and politically unaware politically
unknown dialogue he writes his
impressions of everybody and everything
the State Department for example he
constantly criticized he says working
with the State Department is like
fornicating through a mattress he also
talks about people and he has a very
1960s attitude towards gender for
example he describes flying from
Washington to Hawaii with a American
movie actress at the time and in the
diary says I fell in love before we even
took off and the magic of this voyage
you have to wonder what did his wife
think when she read his diary years
later but it also provides an enormous
amount of in
Nation about what the Indians were
thinking what they were up to how the
United States government worked how the
Kennedy administration worked the inside
workings of the kennedy administration
by somebody who wasn't sitting in the
White House but had a very different
optic sitting in New Delhi watching what
was going on in the White House and one
of the things that really appalled John
Kenneth Galbraith was he could see the
Kennedy administration's sliding into
the Vietnam War and he kept writing the
president saying don't do it don't do it
don't listen to the generals all the
generals are going to get you into a
mess and it's an interesting question of
course another one of the great what-ifs
of the Kennedy administration if Kennedy
had lived would the United States have
gone into the Vietnam War the way that
it tragically did under the Johnson
administration so that's another
perspective that I think you'll find in
this book that you don't find anywhere
else thank you thank you very much for
coming thank you thank you again so much
for coming if you'd like to get a book
please come up say hello get one side if
you can do this a favor and help us by
folding up the chairs and place them
against the bookcases that would be
great have more room to sign thank you
let's have another round of applause
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]